so far I'm supporting Elizabeth Warren
why because she's intelligence she has
integrity she's very well prepared it
says a great track record she cares
about people she's not in it for the
money
and she's never paid a porn star to be
quiet you know everyone loves Jo it's
Uncle Joe you know what I mean but I'm
really interested to see what he's got
to say tomorrow but also just what all
they all have to say about now where we
are in our history and our country and
what they're gonna do moving problem so
what are the issues that are most
important to you as an evangelical who I
had to protect us this shirt is in
regards to his his excellent support you
Colin Kapernick he says no it's not fair
for a man's not to be able to kneel at
the national anthem
even work in this profession without
being blackballed so once we heard that
we know that you think I was really
suffering and what about them if you
don't vote for Beto who would you go
forth they seem to be regular people can
relate to your average America that's
the main reason mr. I actually have a
lot of white friends a lot who are voted
for top we just don't talk politics they
don't like my politics